can throws he was not punishing really
well he was committing to things that he
shouldn't have been committing to uh you
know looking at the level of play that
he we have seen him play at before but
we're gonna be going to the infinite
stage here um and you know no walls in
play i don't know if this is gonna be in
anyone's favor in particular um just
pure secondhand bubsy yeah and you know
what you know i'm a fan of pure tech and
i like the purest of the pure tekken now
like the wall of stages
are like you know is it are they pure
characters though is king are king and
jin pure characters you know i had to i
was gonna say you know when i was
talking about that i had to stop myself
because i don't
because obviously i want to keep my
opinions to myself
all right instantly going in with the
electric off to a quick start bro he
chose war who when you start off with an
electric you do not choose peace you
chose i want war bro like he's starting
a million miles an hour
oh wow
cheese man
that is so unfortunate i had the right
idea there but maybe you just booked the
side a little bit too shallow
so yeah and i think that wasn't in tutu
would have been a better way to go for
that nice launch here we go double rocky
finally get something started oh come on
dude what the hell i mean was that a
mix-up i don't know maybe try to go for
the throw mix up there but rave has seen
that before and opt to just go for the
hot kicks right mix-up yeah i'll put you
matt linda
i mean that that didn't go for a tail
spin there devil rock you're looking
very flustered had to start this match
i've arrived now running away with it
yeah
we've said this before once he gets
started i think this is where he's at
his strongest once he gets that momentum
going that wave that she's moving at you
know 100 miles an hour
yeah
he ain't got a stop sign bro he's just
gonna run you over 100 man he's looking
well who the hell put this guy loser i
think luffy was the one who put right if
he loses but he's looking like he's
unstoppable right now he definitely is
you know he's he's in that loser's
bracket like he knows he's got one life
left maybe it just powers him up maybe
this is his power up you know you have
to be in losers
yeah yeah you know some players are like
that man we've seen it a lot in the icf
seas as well people winning from the
loser side but that's affordable county
and i should be dead
another no round brown can anyone stop
this man devil rocky on the back flip
bubsy it's just once he gets started it
i i don't know what can he do to stop
like he just looks so strong and i've
never seen so many axe kicks actually
hit from he's like he's really got them
to duck or flinch like you don't really
see it that much because the ice kick is
a slower mid launcher sometimes people
can dark and kind of react to it and
stand up in time but it seems to be
really in their head
and uh yeah yeah for sure i mean he's
just on in the zone yeah sometimes
you're just in the zone man everything
you do works out for you he's playing
very solid tight second as well not
giving many opportunities for devil
rocky to get the to get the launches or
any punishment but when he does devil
rocky doesn't maximize on his
opportunities and it's because i'm
telling you it's gotta be nerves man it
has to be you know it's just like this
is not what we're used to seeing from
double rocky we we know he's a lot
stronger than this but rajef is showing
his experience he's showing his
composure and his tenacity in
tournaments and he's i don't know what
the rocky hack has to do here man yeah
well
one he needs to convert fully as you see
he got that launch he um he went for the
wrong combo then i guess he's tried to
make up for it and kind of overextend
and then went into that throw mix up and
reyf was not having it he just saw that
wave dash coming in he's like you know
what i'm gonna place this hot kick right
here and and it hit and in in that sense
it just all that momentum that um he had
it's gone now double rocky had no more
momentum now he's in the launch
situation he's in the okazemi and he's
back in rafe's game so he really needs
to capitalize when he gets these
opportunities he needs to capitalize get
that damage going and
there we go talking about damage
yeah i think he's decided man just to
switch to [ __ ] him this is the character
that we've seen him but we've seen him
play mark and tom we've seen him play
[ __ ] ramen tournament and he's
finally going for a different uh pick
here because the king just hasn't been
working up and you know there's
obviously sometimes in tournament your
main character just doesn't work for you
on the day you have to switch it up yeah
he's going for the big boy from thailand
fakum ram can he make it work here we're
going to the duomo this serious
delicious we're in italy uh you know
he's going at it i was actually hoping
you'd say that name because i was like i
know that i know the stage's name i see
it all the time but pronounce it i am so
bad with pronouncing i just really like
saying it is
serious
teach me teach me this dude
nice yeah
you know how i am with languages
yeah when we were in spain and you were
like i don't i remember that clearly we
were like at the uh supermarket and
they're like uh hola and then he's like
you're like hi
gracias thanks
i'm gonna peep you on this right now
right like when i but if i say those
words i think i sound silly
like you gotta try these look look
listen listen i'm gonna say this bonjour
brother doesn't sound right bro how can
i see french words of the english accent
it just doesn't sound right i just
rather just say hi okay they'll respect
the the attempt though you know
bro i just i just feel like i have not
said it right bonjour
you know
to that kick the holy [ __ ] look at this
rocky looking so different with the
[ __ ] man finally gets around on the
board after how many bloody rounds i
mean yeah well good stuff definitely
is definitely a scary character he's got
a huge damage out but he's a very strong
character even though he's been to be
putting quotations normalized he's still
a very strong character
yeah oh that was a crispy whiff punish
all right there we go take it to the
look at the wall curry is this right
okay this stuff's working crack around
yeah it's a 50 50 on other characters
though isn't it like if you back roll
then it hits you
oh my god jack jack kick oh that kick is
cool it's one of the ones that when you
get hit by it hurts it like stops time
and everything yeah oh try to go for the
rage drive but it's out of it with a jab
drive on the board now but this is
looking way better for double rocky
definitely he's looking more in this
game
okay
oh nice throw break there
looks like it's a late throw break as
well nice oh
nice jesus
that's the thing right has the answers
when you get that momentum going he just
knows how to say no bro yeah i'm taking
this back right now
and with how many strings [ __ ] rum
has i think that
gin can kind of parry against a lot of
them and and shut down the options right
yeah
need to be very careful rage is
available go to the rage drive now not
gonna be huge damage but what's the mix
up
oh nice patience on the floor there from
arriving he stayed on the floor a little
bit delayed his get-up kick and now rife
is on set point to eliminate devil rocky
from the former but a nice punishment
back one again he just he just knows how
to stop people's momentum like like he
said great patience and he even
waited like nope i know right now
stopping momentum
there we go this is a big combo though
nice carry
looking very nice punish there gets the
block punished gonna go towards the wall
nice he stopped it knew he wasn't all
gonna hit great awareness oh boy
oh nice rage drive out of nowhere devil
rocky taking it to a final round can he
get a match on the board bro the way
that race right here i was going to take
him back upstairs
upstairs you've never seen that before
nice combo
all right just shove the wall there's a
beautiful punishment down by four it is
minus 14. yeah
goes into starts nice cancels it make it
safe
okay this is this is devil rocky's last
chance saloon needs this round to stay
in the tournament not like that they'll
get to punish
again he's making he's taking massive
risks here double rocky
a bit of pressure now
nice life father relatively even needs
to be very careful because you've done
that before i'm gonna parry
oh my god no way double rocky is he
gonna get match on the board oh god
is that gonna be it this should be it
yes uses the rage drive to maximize the
damage out there
that's so that's so sad because
devil rocky was he done so much better
there he started to you know get his
game back get his gameplay going but
just
i just fell short there you know just
hell sweet just went for it you know
rolled six on the dice
yeah i feel like i'm probably to blame
for